new this afternoon some new details on  the false alarm at sunday morning at  reed international airport metro police  now say the man who just saw their  33-year-old stephen hutchison walked  right past airport security towards a  terminal he allegedly caused a  disturbance right in the middle of the  airport stole sunglasses from a store  hutchison's also accused of resisting  arrest the incident just caused chaos  though inside the airport on sunday loud  noises were created by land dividers  being pushed down in the commotion and  then passengers had to be re-screened  back into the terminal through tsa  delaying flights for several hours